Moderator: Guten Morgen, liebe Kollegen. Willkommen zu unserem Marketing-Meeting. Heute geht es um die Planung unserer neuen Werbekampagne für die Türgriffabdeckungen. Sind alle da?
[Gemurmel im Hintergrund, Stühle werden gerückt]
Anna: Entschuldigung, ich bin etwas spät. Der Verkehr war heute morgen furchtbar.
Moderator: Kein Problem, Anna. Wir haben gerade erst angefangen. Hat jemand Kaffee mitgebracht?
Markus: Ja, ich habe welchen geholt. Steht hinten auf dem Tisch. Soll ich jemandem eine Tasse bringen?
Moderator: Danke, Markus. Das wäre nett. Also, lasst uns anfangen. Wer möchte die bisherigen Ideen zusammenfassen?
Sarah: Ich kann das machen. Also, wir haben in den letzten Wochen darüber gesprochen, dass wir unsere Türgriffabdeckungen als umweltfreundliche und hygienische Option positionieren wollen. Die Idee war, auf den aktuellen Trend zu nachhaltigen Produkten aufzuspringen.
Thomas: Genau, und wir wollten auch den Aspekt der Individualisierung hervorheben. Viele Kunden wünschen sich ja maßgeschneiderte Lösungen für ihre Türen.
Moderator: Gut, das sind schon mal gute Ansatzpunkte. Hat jemand konkrete Vorschläge, wie wir das umsetzen können?
Anna: Ich dachte an eine Social Media Kampagne. Wir könnten Influencer einsetzen, die zeigen, wie sie ihre Türgriffe mit unseren Produkten aufwerten und gleichzeitig etwas für die Umwelt tun.
Markus: Das klingt interessant. Aber sind Influencer nicht etwas zu... jugendlich für unsere Zielgruppe? Ich meine, wer kauft denn hauptsächlich Türgriffabdeckungen?
Sarah: Da hast du nicht ganz unrecht, Markus. Aber vergiss nicht, dass auch jüngere Menschen Wohnungen einrichten oder renovieren. Außerdem könnten wir auch Business-Influencer ansprechen, die auf LinkedIn oder Xing aktiv sind.
Thomas: Ich finde die Idee gut. Wir könnten auch eine Art Challenge daraus machen. Vielleicht "Zeig uns deinen kreativsten Türgriff" oder so ähnlich.
Moderator: Das sind interessante Ansätze. Anna, kannst du das weiter ausarbeiten und uns beim nächsten Mal eine detailliertere Strategie vorstellen?
Anna: Ja, klar. Ich werde mich darum kümmern.
Markus: Ich hätte da noch eine Idee. Wie wäre es, wenn wir eine Art Konfigurator auf unserer Website einrichten? Kunden könnten dann ihre individuellen Türgriffabdeckungen zusammenstellen und direkt bestellen.
Sarah: Das klingt spannend! Aber wäre das nicht sehr aufwendig in der Umsetzung? Ich meine, sowohl technisch als auch in der Produktion?
Thomas: Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es könnte sich lohnen. Wir könnten damit wirklich einen Mehrwert für unsere Kunden schaffen und uns von der Konkurrenz abheben.
Moderator: Guter Punkt, Thomas. Markus, kannst du mal mit der IT-Abteilung sprechen und abklären, was so etwas kosten und wie lange es dauern würde?
Markus: Ja, mache ich. Ich setze mich heute Nachmittag mit ihnen zusammen.
Anna: Apropos Kosten, haben wir eigentlich schon ein Budget für die Kampagne festgelegt? Ich meine, Influencer-Marketing und ein Online-Konfigurator, das könnte ins Geld gehen.
Moderator: Gute Frage, Anna. Wir müssen das noch mit der Geschäftsführung abstimmen. Aber ich denke, wenn wir ein überzeugendes Konzept vorlegen, sollten wir grünes Licht bekommen.
Sarah: Vielleicht sollten wir auch über klassische Werbung nachdenken. Ich weiß, es klingt altmodisch, aber viele unserer Kunden sind immer noch über Print-Medien zu erreichen.
Thomas: Da hast du recht. Wie wäre es mit Anzeigen in Architektur- oder Einrichtungszeitschriften? Da könnten wir unsere hochwertigen und individualisierbaren Produkte gut präsentieren.
Anna: Gute Idee! Wir könnten auch versuchen, einen redaktionellen Beitrag zu platzieren. Vielleicht über die Bedeutung von Nachhaltigkeit im Innendesign oder so etwas.
Markus: Das gefällt mir. Wir könnten sogar eine Art Serie daraus machen. Jede Ausgabe konzentriert sich auf einen anderen Aspekt: Nachhaltigkeit, Hygiene, Individualisierung...
Moderator: Klingt gut. Sarah, kannst du dich um die Kontakte zu den Zeitschriften kümmern? Vielleicht können wir ja auch ein paar Journalisten zu einer Werksführung einladen.
Sarah: Ja, das übernehme ich gerne. Ich habe da schon ein paar Kontakte, die ich aktivieren kann.
Thomas: Mir ist gerade noch etwas eingefallen. Wie wäre es, wenn wir eine Art "Türgriff des Monats" Aktion machen? Wir könnten jeden Monat eine besonders kreative oder nachhaltige Lösung vorstellen.
Anna: Oh, das finde ich super! Das könnten wir super mit der Social Media Kampagne verbinden. Vielleicht sogar als eine Art Wettbewerb, bei dem Kunden ihre eigenen Designs einreichen können.
Markus: Ja, und der Gewinner bekommt dann... ich weiß nicht, vielleicht eine kostenlose Komplettausstattung für sein Haus oder so was?
Moderator: Das sind wirklich tolle Ideen! Anna, kannst du das in dein Social Media Konzept mit einarbeiten? Und Markus, vielleicht kannst du mal durchrechnen, was so eine Aktion kosten würde.
Anna & Markus: Klar, machen wir.
Sarah: Ich denke, wir sollten auch über den Zeitplan sprechen. Wann wollen wir mit der Kampagne starten? Und wie lange soll sie laufen?
Thomas: Guter Punkt. Ich würde vorschlagen, dass wir im Frühjahr starten. Da denken viele Leute über Renovierungen nach, und es passt gut zum Thema Nachhaltigkeit und Neuanfang.
Anna: Das finde ich auch. Vielleicht können wir die Kampagne an Earth Day oder so ankoppeln? Das würde gut zu unserem Nachhaltigkeitsthema passen.
Moderator: Gute Idee. Lasst uns den Earth Day als Startpunkt nehmen. Das gibt uns... [blättert im Kalender] etwa vier Monate Vorbereitungszeit. Denkt ihr, das reicht?
Markus: Das könnte knapp werden, besonders wenn wir den Online-Konfigurator umsetzen wollen. Aber wenn wir uns ranhalten und vielleicht ein paar Überstunden einplanen, sollten wir das schaffen.
Sarah: Ich stimme zu. Wir sollten aber vielleicht einen Plan B haben, falls sich der Konfigurator verzögert. Vielleicht können wir mit der Social Media Kampagne und den Print-Anzeigen starten und den Konfigurator später nachziehen?
Thomas: Das klingt vernünftig. Wir könnten den Konfigurator ja auch als eine Art "Coming Soon" Feature ankündigen. Das würde Spannung aufbauen.
Moderator: Gute Idee. Also, fassen wir mal zusammen: Wir haben eine Social Media Kampagne mit Influencern, Print-Anzeigen in Fachzeitschriften, einen möglichen Online-Konfigurator und eine "Türgriff des Monats" Aktion. Habe ich etwas vergessen?
Anna: Wir hatten noch die Idee mit den redaktionellen Beiträgen in den Zeitschriften. Und vielleicht sollten wir auch über eine Pressemitteilung zum Start der Kampagne nachdenken?
Sarah: Ja, und wir sollten nicht vergessen, unsere Vertriebspartner zu informieren und einzubinden. Vielleicht können wir ihnen Werbematerialien zur Verfügung stellen?
Markus: Oh ja, das ist wichtig. Wir könnten sogar Schulungen für sie anbieten, damit sie die neuen Nachhaltigkeits- und Individualisierungsaspekte gut an die Kunden kommunizieren können.
Thomas: Und wie wäre es mit einer Roadshow? Wir könnten mit einem mobilen Showroom durch Deutschland touren und unsere Produkte direkt zu den Kunden bringen.
Moderator: Das sind alles großartige Ideen! Ich glaube, wir haben hier wirklich etwas Gutes am Start. Lasst uns die Aufgaben verteilen und beim nächsten Mal die ausgearbeiteten Konzepte besprechen.
Anna: Klingt gut. Ich kümmere mich um das Social Media Konzept und die "Türgriff des Monats" Aktion.
Sarah: Ich nehme Kontakt zu den Zeitschriften auf und arbeite an den redaktionellen Beiträgen. Außerdem kümmere ich mich um die Pressemitteilung und die Einbindung der Vertriebspartner.
Markus: Ich spreche mit der IT wegen des Konfigurators und kalkuliere die Kosten für die verschiedenen Aktionen. Außerdem plane ich die Schulungen für die Vertriebspartner.
Thomas: Und ich kümmere mich um das Konzept für die Print-Anzeigen und die Roadshow-Idee.
Moderator: Perfekt, das klingt nach einem Plan. Noch Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
[Kurze Pause, Gemurmel]
Anna: Mir ist gerade noch etwas eingefallen. Sollten wir vielleicht auch über eine Art Kundenbefragung nachdenken? Um herauszufinden, was unsere Zielgruppe wirklich will?
Sarah: Das ist eine gute Idee. Wir könnten einen kurzen Online-Fragebogen erstellen und ihn über unsere Website und Social Media Kanäle verteilen.
Markus: Ja, und vielleicht können wir auch unsere Vertriebspartner bitten, den Fragebogen an ihre Kunden weiterzuleiten. Das würde uns eine breitere Datenbasis geben.
Thomas: Stimmt, und wir könnten die Ergebnisse dann direkt in unsere Kampagne einfließen lassen. Das würde zeigen, dass wir wirklich auf die Bedürfnisse unserer Kunden eingehen.
Moderator: Das gefällt mir. Anna, kannst du dich um die Erstellung des Fragebogens kümmern? Vielleicht in Zusammenarbeit mit der Marktforschungsabteilung?
Anna: Ja, klar. Ich setze mich gleich morgen mit ihnen zusammen.
Sarah: Apropos Zusammenarbeit, sollten wir vielleicht auch andere Abteilungen in die Kampagne einbinden? Ich denke da an Produktentwicklung oder Qualitätssicherung.
Markus: Gute Idee. Die könnten uns sicher interessante Insights geben, die wir in der Kampagne verwenden können. Vielleicht sogar Testimonials von unseren Ingenieuren?
Thomas: Oh ja, das finde ich gut. "Die Stimmen hinter den Türgriffen" oder so ähnlich. Das würde unseren Produkten ein Gesicht geben.
Moderator: Klingt vielversprechend. Sarah, kannst du dich darum kümmern? Sprich am besten mit den Abteilungsleitern und schau, wer Interesse hat, mitzumachen.
Sarah: Mache ich gerne. Ich denke, das wird gut ankommen.
Anna: Mir ist gerade noch etwas eingefallen. Wie wäre es, wenn wir auch einen Nachhaltigkeitsbericht veröffentlichen? Das würde gut zu unserem neuen Image passen.
Markus: Das ist eine super Idee! Wir könnten darin aufzeigen, wie wir unsere Produktion umweltfreundlicher gestalten und welche Materialien wir verwenden.
Thomas: Ja, und vielleicht können wir auch ein paar Zukunftsprojekte andeuten. Das würde zeigen, dass wir langfristig denken und uns ständig verbessern wollen.
Moderator: Das gefällt mir sehr gut. Anna, kannst du das in dein Kommunikationskonzept mit aufnehmen? Wir müssen natürlich mit der Geschäftsführung und der Produktion sprechen, um die genauen Zahlen und Fakten zu bekommen.
Anna: Klar, ich kümmere mich darum. Soll ich auch gleich einen Termin mit der Geschäftsführung vereinbaren?
Moderator: Ja, das wäre gut. Je früher wir sie ins Boot holen, desto besser. Vielleicht können wir sogar ein Statement vom CEO für den Bericht bekommen.
Sarah: Wenn wir schon beim Thema Nachhaltigkeit sind - wie wäre es, wenn wir eine Kooperation mit einer Umweltschutzorganisation eingehen? Das würde unserer Kampagne noch mehr Glaubwürdigkeit verleihen.
Markus: Oh, das ist interessant. Vielleicht könnten wir für jede verkaufte Türgriffabdeckung einen kleinen Betrag spenden? Oder wir pflanzen einen Baum oder so was?
Thomas: Das klingt gut, aber wir müssen aufpassen, dass es nicht nach Greenwashing aussieht. Vielleicht sollten wir stattdessen eine langfristige Partnerschaft anstreben?
Anna: Ja, das sehe ich auch so. Wir könnten zum Beispiel gemeinsam an der Entwicklung noch nachhaltigerer Materialien arbeiten. Das wäre ein echtes Commitment.
Moderator: Das sind alles sehr gute Ideen. Sarah, kannst du mal recherchieren, welche Organisationen für eine solche Kooperation in Frage kämen? Wir sollten das auf jeden Fall weiterverfolgen.
Sarah: Ja, mache ich. Ich erstelle eine Liste mit potenziellen Partnern und ihren Schwerpunkten.
Markus: Mir fällt gerade ein, dass wir auch über die internationale Ausrichtung der Kampagne nachdenken sollten. Immerhin exportieren wir ja in mehrere Länder.
Thomas: Stimmt, das hatte ich ganz vergessen. Wir müssen die Kampagne wahrscheinlich für verschiedene Märkte anpassen. In manchen Ländern ist Nachhaltigkeit vielleicht nicht so ein großes Thema wie bei uns.
Anna: Guter Punkt. Ich könnte eine Analyse der verschiedenen Zielmärkte machen und schauen, wie wir die Kampagne jeweils ausrichten müssen. Vielleicht müssen wir sogar unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte setzen.
Moderator: Das klingt nach einer Menge Arbeit, aber es ist definitiv wichtig. Anna, kannst du das übernehmen? Vielleicht in Zusammenarbeit mit unseren internationalen Vertriebspartnern?
Anna: Ja, ich kümmere mich darum. Ich werde einen Fragebogen für unsere Partner erstellen, um mehr über die lokalen Märkte zu erfahren.
Sarah: Apropos international - sollten wir vielleicht auch über Messeauftritte nachdenken? Die große Baumesse in Mailand wäre eine gute Gelegenheit, unsere neue Kampagne zu präsentieren.
Markus: Oh ja, Messen hatte ich ganz vergessen. Das wäre wirklich eine gute Plattform. Wir könnten dort auch den Online-Konfigurator vorstellen, wenn er bis dahin fertig ist.
Thomas: Und vielleicht können wir auf der Messe auch eine Art Workshop anbieten? Zum Beispiel wie man mit kleinen Veränderungen wie unseren Türgriffabdeckungen große Wirkung erzielen kann.
Moderator: Das sind alles tolle Ideen. Ich denke, wir sollten definitiv die Messe in unser Konzept aufnehmen. Sarah, kannst du dich um die Organisation kümmern? Und sprich bitte auch mit der Designabteilung wegen eines attraktiven Messestands.
Sarah: Alles klar, ich kümmere mich darum. Soll ich auch gleich nach anderen relevanten Messen suchen?
Moderator: Ja, das wäre gut. Konzentriere dich aber erstmal auf die wichtigsten. Wir können nicht überall sein.
Anna: Mir ist gerade noch etwas eingefallen. Wie wäre es, wenn wir eine Art "Türgriff-Botschafter" Programm starten? Wir könnten zufriedene Kunden dazu einladen, ihre Erfahrungen zu teilen.
Markus: Oh, das gefällt mir! Das wäre wie User-Generated Content, aber auf einer persönlicheren Ebene. Wir könnten sogar kleine Videos produzieren, in denen die Kunden ihre Türen zeigen.
Thomas: Ja, und wir könnten diese Videos dann auf unserer Website, in den sozialen Medien und vielleicht sogar auf Messen zeigen. Das würde unseren Produkten eine sehr authentische Note geben.
Moderator: Das ist eine ausgezeichnete Idee. Anna, kannst du das in dein Social-Media-Konzept einbauen? Und vielleicht können wir auch mit der Kundendienstabteilung sprechen, ob sie uns besonders zufriedene Kunden empfehlen können.
Anna: Ja, ich werde das ausarbeiten. Das könnte wirklich gut ankommen.
Sarah: Wenn wir schon beim Thema Kunden sind - wie wäre es, wenn wir eine Art Loyalitätsprogramm einführen? Zum Beispiel Rabatte für Kunden, die mehrere Türen ausstatten oder uns weiterempfehlen?
Markus: Das ist eine interessante Idee. Wir müssten nur aufpassen, dass wir damit nicht unsere Margen zu sehr schmälern. Aber ein cleveres Loyalitätsprogramm könnte definitiv zu mehr Umsatz führen.
Thomas: Vielleicht könnten wir statt Rabatte zu geben, exklusive Designs oder Sondermodelle anbieten? Das würde unseren Premium-Charakter unterstreichen.
Moderator: Das gefällt mir. Lasst uns das weiter ausarbeiten. Markus, kannst du ein paar Vorschläge für ein solches Loyalitätsprogramm machen? Berücksichtige dabei bitte sowohl finanzielle als auch nicht-finanzielle Anreize.
Markus: Klar, ich werde ein paar Modelle durchrechnen und beim nächsten Mal vorstellen.
Moderator: Gut, ich denke, wir haben jetzt wirklich eine Menge großartiger Ideen zusammengetragen. Lasst uns zum Abschluss noch einmal kurz die wichtigsten Punkte zusammenfassen.
Anna: Also, wir haben eine Social Media Kampagne mit Influencern, Print-Anzeigen, den Online-Konfigurator, die "Türgriff des Monats" Aktion, Kundenbefragungen, einen Nachhaltigkeitsbericht, mögliche Kooperationen mit Umweltorganisationen...
Sarah: ...dazu kommen noch Messeauftritte, das "Türgriff-Botschafter" Programm, die Einbindung anderer Abteilungen für Testimonials, und die Idee für ein Loyalitätsprogramm.
Moderator: Genau, das ist eine ganze Menge. Ich denke, wir haben hier wirklich die Grundlage für eine umfassende und vielversprechende Kampagne. Jeder von euch weiß, was er oder sie zu tun hat?
[Alle nicken zustimmend]
Moderator: Perfekt. Dann treffen wir uns nächste Woche wieder und besprechen die ausgearbeiteten Konzepte. Vielen Dank für eure tollen Ideen und euer Engagement. Das Meeting ist hiermit beendet.
[Stühle werden gerückt, Gemurmel]
Thomas: Oh, eine Sache noch - wer kümmert sich um die Verpflegung für das nächste Meeting? Ich fände ein paar Snacks ganz nett.
Anna: [lacht] Typisch Thomas. Aber er hat recht, bei so vielen Ideen brauchen wir Nervennahrung. Ich kann mich darum kümmern, wenn ihr wollt.
Moderator: [schmunzelnd] Alles klar, Anna übernimmt die Snacks. Dann bis nächste Woche, gleiches Büro, gleiche Zeit!
[Verabschiedungen, Geräusche von Leuten, die den Raum verlassen]